[Music]
the katy freeway in texas
connects houston's western suburbs with
the city's downtown
at its widest point right here it spans
26 lanes including parallel roads
before it intersects with another
freeway creating this massive web of
pavement
the katy freeway is among the widest in
the world but it didn't start out this
big
the freeway was initially built in the
1960s with six lanes in most places
but as the suburbs and office space
around houston started growing in the
1980s and 90s
and more people began using the freeway
it became a traffic nightmare
by 2004 it was ranked the second worst
bottleneck in the country
to accommodate the growing commuter
class the city began a nearly 3 billion
expansion project to add the additional
lanes
the solution seems natural more lanes
equals less congestion
but traffic didn't get any better in
fact it got worse
in both the morning and afternoon
commutes
the reason why hinges on a simple
economic theory
one that is often overlooked because
actually reducing traffic
is far from simple
highway expansion has gone hand in hand
with the suburbanization of american
cities like houston
it becomes a self-fulfilling recipe for
urban sprawl
a highway gets built to connect suburbs
to a city center
which encourages more development along
it which necessitates even more highways
when those get congested
and on and on and on the instinct to
widen highways to relieve traffic makes
sense
but there's a reason it doesn't work due
to a concept called induced
demand these represent three highway
lanes
and these balls are the commuters that
drive on them these particular commuters
the red ones will sit in traffic no
matter how bad it gets
because they have to driving to work on
the highway is their only option
this is what congestion looks like
during peak rush hours
once a certain number of cars get on the
highway traffic slows to a crawl
now let's add a new lane these drivers
now have more room to spread out which
should make traffic flow better
that might happen at first but it
doesn't stay that way
that's because there's another set of
people who will take the highway under
the right conditions
even though they have other commuting
options when a highway is congested
they might take local roads instead or
be able to drive during off-peak hours
they might use other modes of
transportation like public transit
or biking or maybe they can work from
home that day and skip the commute
altogether
in a few years these people will start
taking the highway
enticed by less congestion this is
induced demand at play
the more supply there is the more demand
will follow to exhaustion
and in this case the supply is highway
lanes and sometimes like on the katy
freeway
congestion gets even worse after a
highway expansion until some of the
people with more options go back to
their old ways
but in the end you're still left with
more drivers in congestion that's at
least as bad as it was before
when our transportation system is so
reliant on highways
and private automobiles there's there's
almost no
way around it because that's that's the
system that we've created
this is kyle shelton an urbanist based
in houston the endless reduction of
congestion
should that be the drive honestly the
driving policy
question for a lot of our transportation
funding big expensive highway
infrastructure projects are still the
prevailing band-aid to congestion in the
u.s
the transit advocacy group
transportation for america
found that between 1993 and 2017
the us added over 30 000 miles of new
freeway lanes in a hundred metro areas
building more highways may provide some
short-term relief
and it's easier than most infrastructure
projects to get federal funding to do a
highway expansion
but if we want less traffic and fewer
drivers
giving flexible commuters better choices
is a good place to start
like by improving public transit by
adding more and better bus routes or
trains
that alone might not be a silver bullet
for congestion relief
for the same reason that adding another
lane isn't new drivers will take the
place of transit commuters on the
highway
and for many people living off highways
and sprawling u.s cities
public transit may never be an adequate
solution because it's not just about the
infrastructure it's also about
individual behaviors it's about where
job opportunities are located
and most of our cities have now been
constructed in this way where the car
is the prime mode
[Music]
another option is to enact policies that
actively disincentivize people from
using the highway
like congestion pricing which charges
people who drive on highways during rush
hours
or remote work programs that deter
people from traveling during the highest
traffic times
or make it so they don't have to commute
at all and in the long term better land
use policies can help as well
like by building communities that put
people closer to where they need to go
and if building more highways results in
more drivers and congestion
then removing them could have the
opposite effect
for example the city of boston removed a
freeway in its city center in the 1990s
and replaced it with a boulevard with
biking and bus lanes and more space to
walk
it reduced congestion by 62 percent
and now the democratically controlled
senate is considering nearly 10 billion
in funding for similar highway removal
projects in other cities
what we build and invest in in the world
of transportation truly changes our
behavior
if building more roads makes us drive on
them more then giving people better
choices by investing in the right things
will make us drive less because if we
build it
they will come
[Music]
you